welcome back everybody the cast of Rose
is with us Billy Eichner Simone
to celebrate their new movie we wanted
to play a game to honor the lgbtq plus
community and Billy was kind enough to
choose a game called share the love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is just to make her way up to the
firemen
I love it really just like oh I need to
for the music
Jim Rash agreed to host teams are Luke
and me versus Billy and Simone basically
I just it seemed like really fun to beat
Billy so that's why I did it like this
wow oh yeah it's on Bring it on
Drake
[Applause]
how does the game go if I may just real
quick because this could be great
audition tape for game show hosts hi Jim
Rash five nine
Los Angeles based and I'm auditioning
for the role of game show
it could be it
five nine is might be debatable all
right here we go based on this shot
where I am okay here we go the game is
simple I'll ask a question about a gay
icon of which there are many uh and
whichever team can be the first to buzz
in and give the correct answer gets a
point but answer wrong and the other
team can steal so let's be careful now
you can't answer before I'm done reading
but I have a lovely speaking voice so
that uh might be disappointing to
everybody but it will cost you okay if
you're wrong okay so if Billy and Simone
win their photos will be ceremoniously
mounted on the chicks wall of Champs who
beat Kelly
[Music]
whatever okay okay
and away we go okay okay uh hands
hovering or somewhere near the buzzer
okay first question before she enjoyed
the view or even had her own talk show
this comedic icon was in a League of her
own Rosie O'Donnell
[Music]
yeah
okay all right well I'm feeling good
zero yeah I get it Jim I get it it says
it says okay uh next question this icon
released her album Renaissance this
summer
Beyonce
[Applause]
these buzzers are working flawlessly
okay next question he was the first
openly gay man to be elected to public
office in California and a yes Harvey
Harvey Milk that is
[Applause]
two points
it's good for a host to judge the people
who are losing
uh next question uh this New York uh
born icon reminded us all that we're on
the right track baby because we're born
Born This Way Lady Gaga
[Applause]
Tim McGraw
here we go next question this iconic
vocalist was born with four extra teeth
in the back of his mouth and never had
them fixed because he was afraid it
would ruin his voice what yeah I'm gonna
guess Freddie Mercury
[Applause]
very good wow
three points
next question if you're if you're Billy
Eichner good luck uh you saw her in
concert with your hair oh Barbra
Streisand
[Applause]
wow
all right here we go it is 4-2 all right
uh this icon was the first drag queen to
get his star on the Hollywood Walk of
yes
[Applause]
it is 4-3 and this is the last question
however it is worth seven points okay
wow okay okay all right uh this icon was
the first woman to win the album of the
Year Grammy over two decades after she
dropped a house on a witch
um
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you know how intense I am wow I'm
sweating
so that sound that I did not hear means
the game is over
thank you
thank you
thank you for everybody
the effort was appreciated
once again Bros opens in theaters
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]